[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
money doesn't make everything it really
just doesn't make everything great you
know no it doesn't
it helps sometimes it helps things yeah
what'd they say somebody said it helped
me make you warm in the winter and cool
in the summer so that's what somebody
said right that's a poor person saying
that
it's a homeless person's idea of what
money is you get cool and warm
it's like no there's many other things
you get
that's an insane that's like the lowest
level of what money can do
do you think you get water when you're
thirsty and
food when you're hungry oh money
oh man you get mittens
i don't really care about confederate
monuments but it's like then it's like
well let's get rid of
uh you know washington right lincoln
let's get rid of mount rushmore it's
like
where does it end and the other question
nobody asks
what do you replace that with right what
are we replacing it with
right because you're going to lose a lot
of branding like even like the
university george washington university
right like
they've been thinking like okay do we
have to change has been like
yeah they just change it to gw and
nobody it's enough they'll be like it's
gw
it's like kfc when they were like not
using chicken
yeah it's kfc you're like yeah but what
does that c stand for they're like i
don't know
something crunchy yeah we don't know
what it is okay they have these big
marches where four
nazis show up and then 30 000 protesters
show up and they're like we're defending
civilization
from these four and it's just like four
fat guys with
helmets they taped onto their head with
like
you know like weird white supremacist
signs and they're and they're being
guarded by 20 police officers
to protect their free speech and they're
like they just have the signs up
and then there's like 30 000 lesbians
with green hair just throwing rocks
at these four guys and it's like but
also trying to steal their outfits yeah
right it's just like oh this is
chivalrous and they throw milkshakes at
each other
yo i heard i heard they fill those
milkshakes with quick cement quick
driving no but it's like
someone heard that they look like
milkshakes and they're really just like
hard little cylinders cement wow
that we're having a dessert themed
revolution
people chucking brownies at each other
my cousin [ __ ] took a creme brulee to
the [ __ ] sternum the other day really
what happened the same just [ __ ] got out
of hand yeah
that's [ __ ] great though well it's
definitely the most are so
good bro it's entertaining right now who
who got him can you say it it's
entertaining huh can you say
a black woman interesting great was it
that's what i was picturing
before you vocalized it i wanted to make
sure i wasn't racist
no you're not right right it's not
racist just if a black person's involved
in something it's not racist i agree
with you
otherwise the whole nfl would be racist
why not appreciate it why not look at
his statue and go
yeah that guy did some [ __ ] like why
are statues only of good people
number one like the idea that every
statue it doesn't mean that i never look
at his statue and go that was a great
guy
that guy was great i bet he was great i
never have ever looked at his stature
and went
i should think like him yeah i look at a
statue and go that guy did something
maybe good maybe very bad
he might have been very bad but it was
significant
that's what a statue is it's about
significance it's not about moral purity
right that was the guy was a role player
he like threw up a carmelo anthony
somewhere yeah you know what i'm saying
like
right he kind of like people are 50 50
on if he's really that helpful to a team
right you know everyone's had this
experience in l.a where you you know
this actor who's got the most the
bubbliest personality on screen
yeah and then you say hi to him in real
life and they're they suck yeah the kid
from
shelbyville sucked the life out of here
literal piece of [ __ ] and i hate his
guts
i was like yo what up sheldon you just
stared at me and i was like i'll kick
you in the chat in the net
you know what i mean hey can you can you
kick people in the neck
i could try i would have to get a train
a gay guy you can do a lot more stuff
and i know i'm not just saying you're
gay i know you're a lot of different
stuff but
yeah you can as a gay man you can kick
somebody in the [ __ ] neck and you're
kind of okay with it i don't think
a straight man or you know i'm not the
type of gay guy to get away with that
like
if if if the jesse smell that hate crime
people happen to me people be like oh
good
like if they showed my face they'd be
like two guys hit him they'd be like
good
no news story well good i'm glad he got
hit
and that and next so it's like a certain
gay guys get away with it
certain gay guys are like yeah go good
for mardi gras we would go by the um
we would go by the everybody would meet
at the robert e lee statue in new
orleans right right
and everybody would meet there black
white right that's all we had we had a
little bit of like
i guess maybe mexican or chinese like
kind of like one person
might have been a pacific islander yeah
something yeah gotcha like
like i grew up in a town we had a group
called wham whites against mexicans
right
yeah and we didn't have any mexicans so
they would always is that a musical
group
no this is not okay this is more of like
a get the torch
yeah just like a budget antifa you know
like antifa but that had to be home by 6
p.m for dinner
gotcha okay and then and it was only
three guys in it right
um and then they like kind of attacked
the chinese like semi-chinese kid once
like there was no
real follow-through you know but is it
because they couldn't find a mexican
yeah there was
no let's just get let's just get this
guy he's semi-changed
totally yeah yeah oh my brother it's the
best we're gonna do we just gotta we
gotta show people we're about it and
there's no mexicans around
but this guy looked half chinese yeah so
he's getting it shows people you could
have all this stuff you can have all the
money you could have all the fame
you could be very talented you could
still not be happy you could still have
a lot of those problems
yeah you know helps me perspective real
like persp like whenever i'm having just
a
[ __ ] day and i'm like one of the worst
you know sued for like hundreds of
thousands of dollars like hurt myself in
boxing in the morning
and it's like sick and i'm just like
[ __ ] nothing's going right i'm always
like someone someone somewhere has it so
much worse
yeah you know lots of people yeah you
know so like i
haven't yeah continents haven't worked
that's what i'm saying i'm right here so
entire hemispheres haven't worked i love
how you're like
someone like he wakes up wherever he is
beverly hills he's like there's got to
be someone out there who's having a bad
day today like i'm having a bad day
there's got to be some other person out
here let's see let's go to a guy right
here we got a guy right here who has
excited guys having a worse dad
this guy he's just driving a prison bus
yeah he is actually
here's what i think it is i think
outside there's gonna be like
fights and and people be fighting each
other
hopefully they'll be fist fighting each
other inside of an olive garden olive
garden will become
it'll be a place for fighting
government's gonna be like snatching
people off
it's gonna be crazy right and then
you'll be inside your house
with like vr goggles on like doing
tick-tock dances
and outside there's gonna be explosions
and you're just gonna hear gunshots and
then you just can't hear it because
you're in like this
augmented reality world of like the
whole thing is we just climbed into the
computer yeah when
when this started everybody was just
like well the outside's a problem you're
going to get sick
somebody's going to you know oh that's
true now we've all climbed into the
computer i'm in the computer we're just
going to live there forever
so humanity will it'll just get weirder
and weirder and weirder
to the point where if you're like hey
you want to go to the park somebody's
gonna be looking you go are you [ __ ]
sick
are you a [ __ ] sicko do you know
what's out there marauding gangs
coronaviruses diseases government agents
like
it's gonna get pedophilia
[Applause]
and i think tick-tock is a great way to
take a glimpse into the future
because the news will be like
everybody's dying
and then the kids on tick tock are just
like yeah
you know just like this like
just just unbothered just completely
like
like they're teletubbies yeah just like
some kids getting molested and the
teletubbies are just dancing on the
screen and they're just like
mouthing the words to songs they didn't
write yeah
and they're just dancing and then and
that's
kind of the beginning of of and then you
have this girl who mouths trump like
sarah cooper whatever her name is
who's whatever talented i'm not cheating
on her but like she just
like trump she like lip syncs trump so
he'll say something and she goes on tick
tock she's got this massive following
just like lip syncing
so it's gonna be weird it's just like
it's gonna be like
people lip syncing music or the words of
other people and people can be like
that's funny
it's kind of it's starting to feel
strange out there and i think it just
gets weirder and weirder
to the point where we all just want to
live in a video game
because it's more comforting than real
life and what about if semen comes out
of our bodies we just throw it away we
just
it'll come out of your body you'll just
throw it away but i think a lot of it
will be like
will somebody come to collect it it'll
be it'll be sex robots it'll be stim
it'll be weird stimuli
it'll be they'll still be [ __ ] and
everything but it'll be just a weird
it's going to go into you know the way
that these augmented reality games or
virtual reality feels i think that it's
very possible that like porn gets
so [ __ ] powerful and crazy way
powerful already that who knows
it's destroying people's real sex drives
it's destroying people's yeah i'm one of
those people yeah
we'll never know i mean that's i mean he
was clearly either murdered or allowed
to kill himself i mean that you have
narcoleptic prison guards you have
malfunctioning cameras you have him
making a will the day before he died and
you have
him being taken off suicide watch 48
hours before he died
i mean to if you don't believe there's
something going on you're in on it
yeah that's the way i feel like if you
don't believe him buying a
sorry i'm dead shirt on amazon two days
before
yeah i mean him having dinner last night
in west hollywood
that was a little suspicious having a
dinner party
called welcome jeffrey to the hood that
was odd
his new job at the disney channel
questionable
questionable when jenny slate uh
apologized for doing the voice of a
mixed race character on big mouth yeah i
saw that i did this whole thing on my
podcast as a joke where i was like
it's not enough that she's stepping down
because her apology is very creepy right
people i was like why why does she jenny
slate from everything i know about her
is probably not like a racist right
why is she coming out to like confess
she's like i've erased black people
i cannot believe and it was very weird
like she felt she had to come out and
give this
big explanation it was very weird so i
just said
you know to counter the insanity of that
i said that's not enough she should go
to jail
yeah she should be in jail you know i
think she should go to jail
i saw this every day jenny slate is not
in jail i will speak out yeah and that's
the whole thing because i said it's not
enough
so this is what you kind of do when
people go woke
you just go further right you go
you go wide awake yeah yeah you go real
yeah wide awake you go to insomnia yeah
you go put her in jail
yeah put her in check that's not enough
and who are her parents where they live
and where are they let's share this
we're burning that house
you raised a racist yeah get them let's
share
their information and what that's
supposed to do is make people go oh yeah
this is stupid
but as a matter of fact you get people
on twitter going i don't think she
should go to jail and then some people
go
maybe like a re-education
you're like yeah maybe like some type of
re-education or something but not
jail next you know she has to take 40
hours of school yeah driving from
an african-american instructor yeah
what's great is like i'm like oh you're
almost there like you're almost at my
crazy example
right you're almost at let's put her in
jail yeah that's what you see when you
tweet something crazy
and the responses are like yeah that
might make some sense you're like what
who would be in the undercard of your of
your bouts i want him on now
yeah who would he fight though i don't
know it's a good question let's have it
be a woman let's start small
there needs to be another gay man
because we can bring back the the gay
boxing what about a tran
what about a woman who's now a man
can i fight a woman a woman who's now
identifies as a man
i think you guys can if you wear
matching just
let me tell you right now i will do that
please speak to you people i will do
that
uh if everyone's good with it i'm in my
my agent will be so excited they'll be
like how was that podcast i'm like
you're never going to believe it
i'm fighting a trans person at the
staples center you're like my age
thank god you're like me thank god this
is a good year this is a good year me
and chelsea handler are about to [ __ ]
go
dude i would love to hit chelsea she's
two arguments away from dropping a set
of nuts
i saw her on a plane the other day and
she just she looks mean
she looks so mean but why do some rich
people get
so mean i don't know but she looks super
mean dude
she looks like somebody would kick a
service dog yeah
[Music]
the wrong way